[Música]
[Aplausos]
e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
bem com você e muitas vezes já pode ter
visto ou não tinha isso indo só ajudou o
fulano de tal e comprar tal coisa ruim
diz ajudou fulana comprará a cadeira de
rodas nos ajudou fulano a comprar no seu
que para um universidade muita gente me
pergunta por que tu faz isso é o
seguinte pra eu sei o que é precisar das
coisas quando eu era criança meu pai
vendia remédios na roça ele ia para a
roça sabe remédio genérico sem dor de
cabeça dor de dente gripe só dizem sim
muita vergonha da roça mais pobre tem
condição de na cidade fazer uma consulta
fazer alguma coisa meu pai ele ele vende
remédio eu e meu pai é pequenininho
assim conservar meus seis anos e meu pai
na moto eu aqui atrás ea caixa de
remédio atrás meu pai vendia e muitas
vezes para chegar por um remédio em casa
pessoa falar agora que é muito bom com
dor de cabeça a mulher falava assim eu
estou morrendo de dor de cabeça tem uma
dor de cabeça que tem dez anos que não
acaba mas eu infelizmente não tenho
dinheiro pra compartilhar meu pai falava
pode ficar outra vez que eu passo aqui
se ela tiver eu falo com você mas também
tiveram preciso que a pessoa muitas
vezes o dinheiro pra pagar vai falar mas
é que se está com fome só criança está
com fome que aqui tem almoço a gente
comia comia que era uma beleza eu morrer
de fome como pra [ __ ] cometou a
melhorar mas secreta para almoçar na
casa das pessoas porque meu pai chegava
na casa do seu pai e avô de pediam como
era criança de escada falar pai tô com
fome com sono fome zero primeiro boom dá
psiu perguntar porque é que o meu pai
quero às vezes chegava na comida eu nem
gostava comigo nem com meu pai vá pra
comer que só cada criança pequena
criança que conforme modelo nessa hora
eu como a equipe só papel e comida por
isso que ajuda é bom ajuda é bom porque
você recebe as coisas em troca sem pedir
é que ele vai ditar que parece um clichê
mas é verdade é dando que se recebe uma
para esse dia chegou nos comentários no
facebook falou o seguinte eu trabalho
com música no hospital leva música com
as crianças no hospital hospital para
crianças com câncer
só tem um problema
visitas ao hospital mas este hospital
está precário pra [ __ ]
esse hospital fiquei imperatriz no
maranhão então esse rapaz falou comigo
ele não falou comigo porque pensando
cara e como é que eu vou ajudar um
hospital porque isso não é dever meu
esse é um dever dos governantes das
pessoas tal não adianta dar um pouco não
dá para fazer nada não dá para ajudar
tudo que faz é albino trabalho como
falar o infarto é um aplicativo se chama
pp que quem entrar em contato com você
pra fazer alguma coisa com você eles
estão o negócio muito mais chamado
agosto verde eles podem fazer uma parada
assim se a pessoa baixar e usar o teu
código ela venha r$10 para fazer uma
doação falei lhe deu 7 meu deus eu vou
mudar certas coisas escreve certo por
linhas de coisa colina e eu falei fala
com oscar vamos fazer agora papal e com
que é isso vou explicar é o nome do
aplicativo é pp está aqui ele funciona
como uma carteira virtual server
mercadante observou chega o dinheiro em
baixa o aplicativo criança conta
cadastra sua conta que a mesma do banco
natal um exemplo vamos fazer um
churrasco beleza galera hoje eu pago cem
reais depois cada um me dá 10 pode ser
beleza eu joguei com a conta no ppi pode
botar 10 reais cada um na sua conta e
vai aparecer
fulano de tal pagou hinos que bastava
ver flame tal pessoa pode curtir fulano
que pagou a inox e do aplicativo já tem
lá é o saldo de um botão pagasse clicou
em pagar vai abrir o negócio vai ter lá
no cantinho agosto verdes e clicou lá
vai ter uma instituição depois do ar
inclusive a do pessoal de imperatriz no
maranhão e crianças com câncer um música
no hospital a arroba música no hospital
recapitulando esse baixo fitei cadastro
tempo para cadastrar o seu uso meu
código está aqui já que está escrito meu
nome certinho o windows ou sem sair com
dez reais já e você pode ir lá no agosto
verde e do ar lá embaixo a roupa música
no hospital clica nele e clique em pagar
quem vai cair 10 reais pra eles lá cara
mais uma ajuda tão grande porque a gente
vai poder realmente fazer um negócio
grande que dê para realmente fazer
mudanças em alguma coisa e não só doam
dinheiro aqui e depois vai precisar
depois para remendar e depois de o
parlamento da lei que vai precisar pra
remendar e não a gente vai conseguir
fazer eu vou fazer uma doação também boa
e bem gordas e o que você está pensando
eu queria muito que você compartilhar
esse vídeo parte mais gente baixa o
aplicativo usa o código
saiba r$10 do mpu música na escola a
gente poder fazer uma revolução nessa
etapa essas crianças com cancro que você
puder fazer por esse vídeo vai ajudar a
curtir aquele youtube orkut no facebook
compartilhamento no facebook você está
vendo este vídeo aqui no posto facebook
compartilhar comentário aqui no youtube
meio sei lá um comentário uma palavra de
ânimo para william que é o cara que é
idealizador desse projeto pode comentar
aqui até uma palavra bonita tudo ajuda
tudo ajuda eu estava falando sempre pra
vocês no estoque estavam conectando
quanto que tá caindo lá pra eles porque
a gente já conseguiu ajudar nos estoques
no twitter vou falar do inep e vou falar
em tudo pra vocês ficarem sabendo isso é
muito obrigado clique gostei e se
inscreve no canal e hoje não vou pedir
record dele que não houve recorde de
doação pra vocês recorde de download
para a gente poder do amor que é tão
fácil às vezes você pensa assim é é
parece uma foto de fulano fulano precisa
de doação total e você pensa que é um
trabalho pegar aquela conta e às vezes
no banco a fazer transferência que nem
pelo celular e com isso ficou tão fácil
agora é só baixar se cadastrar você usa
o meu código e já sai com dez reais para
doar para roubar música na escola você
corria tanto tempo com os meus vídeos aí
sei la sorrir um celular na mão celular
assim mas deixa cair na cara notebook um
computador mesmo trabalho agora no
ônibus ou no meio da rua já assistimos
agora eu estou assistindo agora de
madrugada o que realmente tem nada pra
fazer melhor acho que agora é uma boa
hora de você retribuir esses sorriso
coloquei na tua cara às vezes é pra
fazer uma criancinha lá de imperatriz no
maranhão que às vezes não têm nem muita
esperança que às vezes falta esperança
para pessoas a pessoa pensa que não vai
dar certo não vai sair daqui chegou a
hora de você colocar um sorriso
essa pessoa a minha doação vai ser bem
boa a só pra avisar vocês só que com a
ajuda de vocês vai ficar melhor ainda e
eu só orgulho de você viu sangue ou de
você que está fazendo isso para ajudar
onde você está até aqui comigo hoje
vamos junto valeu william
falei para treinar maranhão e criança
seja assistindo agora você quer do
hospital e tranquilo que vai dar tudo
certo toda essa galera que me segue toda
essa galera que está aqui comigo há
tanto tempo junto com você também está
são 22 milhões de pessoas segurando a
somando junto um beijo